[Musique]
écoutez bien cette musique
vous la connaissez sans doute non si
stan six icônes de la musique d'un sol à
la jamaïque et même dans le monde entier
son titre bam bam à 2 sa création en
1982 jusqu'à aujourd'hui traversé les
époques sans prendre une ride
il est même devenu l'un des titres les
plus simples et au monde un exemple
parfait pour illustrer l'histoire qui va
suivre l'histoire d'un genre musical qui
ne laisse personne indifférent quel que
soit l'âge ou la catégorie sociale
bah
alors laissez moi vous raconter cette
histoire avec pour commencer quelques
petites piqûres de rappel
et oui le petit sourire que vous
esquissez aucoin veut tout dire
quand on se remémore des souvenirs à
l'écouté de ces musiques des années 90
qui ont bercé l'époque et traverser les
frontières
pateras shaggy bariton lévis
beenie man
non
oh
buju banton
[Musique]
shabba ranks
mois un peu plus récemment à partir des
années 2000 au moins des champions
ou encore patrice carter
autant d'artistes qui ont marqué
l'histoire du dancehall et continue à
sourire
alors pour comprendre cette musique
cette culture à part entière nous allons
sillonner les rues de kingston en
passant par les studios d'enregistrement
les sound systems selecta à l'ancienne
les concerts
l'université
ou encore les bains sol stigmatise
nous allons aussi rencontrer ceux qui
ont lancé le mouvement d'un sol
ceux qui ont choisi leur propre style
plus mystique
et aussi ceux qui n'en font plus partie
malgré leur succès jazz
et hip hop découvrez l'histoire du
dancehall
sous tous ses angles
22h30 dans un des studios de la banlieue
de kingston
une session d'enregistrement comme il y
en a beaucoup ici
kingston ce n'est pas seulement la
capitale économique de la jamaïque c'est
aussi et surtout sa capitale musicale et
ce studio n'est pas n'importe lequel
ici de nombreuses pointures du dancehall
du reggae ont enregistré leur album le
studio big horn est devenu populaire
grâce à shaggy qui enregistre la plupart
de ses albums
c'est donc dans les pas de ces artistes
reconnus que mr jean a aussi envie de
marcher
[Musique]
depuis plus de dix ans ils baignent dans
cet univers quelques-uns de ses titres
lui assure une petite notoriété locale
alors il ne lâche pas la faire le
dancehall c'est tout s'arrête
[Musique]
à
ce que la musique d'un seul est l'une
des musiques les plus puissants sur la
planète terre
les médias radio télé c'est la musique
qui continuera de voyager partout dans
le monde en face des artistes qui feront
les plus grandes scènes
c'est ce qu'on appelle une musique de la
mode notre musique touche les gens au
plus profond de leur coeur
c'est bon ça que c'est la promotion des
musiques sur
pas de musique dancehall son compositeur
ce qui lui donne cette localité il ce
rythme si particulier et différent kamal
evans travail depuis son plus jeune âge
sur les tables de mixage et les
logiciels de composition après une
carrière ratée en tant que dj il se
tourne vers ce métier dans lequel il va
se démarquer
les base instrumentale du taennchel
sacré jamais qu il ya le plus souvent de
la batterie et ont volé
c'est plutôt leurs huit la basse
aujourd'hui plus différent mais on
insiste toujours sur les vertus sous guy
labertit
c'est quoi la différence aujourd'hui
l'évolution c'est que c'est moi de
la jamaïque que s'est placé sur la carte
du monde grâce au reggae ils sont
ambassadeurs bob marley dans les années
qui suivent l'indépendance de la
jamaïque la musique reggae la culture
rastafari sont indissociables de l'image
de l'île et à partir des années 70 le
succès commercial du reggae est
considérable il laisse une forte
empreinte et prend tout comme le
dancehall ses origines dans le ska
[Musique]
le ska
est un style musical qui a émergé à la
jamaïque dans les années 60
il se caractérise par an sont rythmés et
se reconnaît grâce à ces contretemps
marquée par la guitare les claviers et
les cuivres
la particularité du scar une musique que
l'on danse sur les pistes et qui va
donner lieu bien à malley au sound
system
[Musique]
le ska et donc l'ancêtre du reggae et in
extenso celui du dancehall d'un sol qui
littéralement veut dire salle de danse
petit retour chronologique
le ska émergent donc dans les années 60
le et reggae prend le relais dans les
années soixante dix
puis vient l'avènement du dancehall dans
les années 80 jusqu'à nos jours
la tradition musicale jamaïcaine c'est
donc le fruit de tous ces mélanges et
ses évolutions musicales et sociétal sur
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années
[Musique]
le reggae une tradition que denver a
préféré perpétuer plutôt que de se
lancer dans le dancehall
ancien élève de l'alphabet school
institute de kingston
denver adopte le style qui se rapproche
le plus de ses goûts personnels de sa
formation musicale ainsi que des
messages qu'il a envie de véhiculer
[Musique]
avec la musique reggae ans touche l'âme
des gens le dancehall parle plutôt des
problèmes il parle des situations qui se
passe sur le moment le reggae parle des
solutions aux problèmes
tant
que musicien reggae quelle est votre
vision de sur la musique d'un seul
trophée de la ville le dancehall et
comme il a abdiqué leur jazz manouche à
paillettes d'elimane toute cette
nouvelle génération
nous avons vu la jeunesse du dancehall
son rapport au reggae son histoire ses
origines ses ancêtres et ce qui le
caractérise
passons maintenant à ses acteurs ses
pionniers ceux qui ont lancé le
mouvement
au mouzon morose en
cette ère fredonner sont les premières
notes d'un titre bien connu dans le
milieu zoug ouzou goujon xing et le
morceau emblématique du dancehall des
années 80
son interprète yellowman est la plus
grande star de l'époque
albinos il va faire de son handicap une
force qui va s'imposer sur les scènes
locales jusque dans les plus grandes
villes du monde
[Musique]
il fait ses débuts en tant que dj dans
les sound systems puis il perce en
gagnant un concours de chant qui le
propulse sur le devant de la scène
commence alors une success story pour
cet homme qui toasts de façon originale
à l'époque
martinez elle s'est fait dans le passé
chaque système avec dj dance hall comme
j'ai joué dans beaucoup de sang système
est à nationaux et
[Musique]
il y avait aussi charlie chaplin young
seo graf
je suis le premier artiste d'un seul à
avoir fait cette tournée live avec mes
musiciens
[Musique]
et aux tonga pourrait donc amener le
dancehall ronde comme marley
a pu le faire avec le reggae
c'est comme cela que le d'un seul est
devenu populaire qui aimons
et la nouvelle génération bénéficié de
ça
à votre époque les paroles étaient
différentes
les sonorités différentes
tout était différent
oui oui oui c'est vrai ça vend les
sonorités d'insolites et défendent en
lien avec le
nom
aujourd'hui c'est une qui est mélangée
au dancehall et
le mât n'a perdu son aura dans les
années 90 avec l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
génération d'artistes d'un seul et même
après un sévère cancer qui lui a valu
l'ablation d'une partie de son visage
à 63 ans jan hommen reste très sollicité
et continue ses tournées dans de
nombreux pays
se sont dans des sons système à quelques
détails près comme celui ci
que yellowman s'est fait connaître
ce soir-là à l'ambassade or on se
replonge dans l'époque dès débuts avec
une soirée selecta du dancehall un peu
de reggae musique le tout mixé par des
dj
une discothèque ambulante que l'on
appelle son système s'installe andré des
envies en plein air ou en salle
et le personnage central de ces sondes
système c'est lui le selector qui joue
ses disques et à nîmes en même temps au
micro
une joie uniquement que de la musique
jamaïcaine habituellement c'est la
musique reggae mais nous jouons souvent
du dancehall dancehall avec les prix dit
et pas de nouveaux morceaux on ne joue
pas assez bord cela vient des endroits
peau ça sinon
le but du sound system faire danser le
public leur faire découvrir des
nouveautés des nouveaux artistes ou
rejouer des tubes tout simplement je
parle en tant que danseur je suis là
pour m'amuser jusqu'à maintenant aux
gens peuvent ils bien
je vois bien l'évolution
quand j'étais petit je ne faisais qui
peut que cette musique
maintenant je chante et je la partage
avec le maigre ici c'est très
nostalgique ça replonge dans le passé
des sound systems qui ont rapidement
pris une place importante dans le
paysage musical
des sound systems qui ont joué un rôle
important dans l'évolution des
techniques et des styles
des sound systems qui ont fait émerger
des talents
le retour aux sources de cette soirée
selecta remet sous le feu des
projecteurs dès chanteur bien connu de
l'époque
comme tantôt métro et des ventes et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est du dancehall levrel authentique
de vraie musique dancehall à des
passionnés on prend plaisir à chanter ça
qu'elle ça c'est bien
aujourd'hui les lieux d'expression du
dancehall nouvelle génération ressemble
un peu plus à cela
l'étymologie du mot il prend alors tout
son sens
dans une banlieue populaire de kingston
de minuit jusqu'à 7 heures du matin le
des rêves accueille tous les jeudis soir
les amoureux de danse et de musique
dance hall c'est le lieu par excellence
de l'expression corporelle des jeunes
jamaïcains
[Musique]
tous les codes de la culture d'un seul
sont présents
les hommes sont stylés aucun détail
n'est négligé de la tête aux pieds on se
doit de briller au sens propre comme au
figuré
[Applaudissements]
les femmes quant à elles doivent être
sexy et surtout visible
place donc aux couleurs vives et plus
haut des vêtements très près du corps
laissant voir toutes leurs formes
car la danseuse de dames seule doit
incarner le sensuel dans la provocation
ce qui peut ailleurs paraître vulgaire
et sexuelle est en fait une forme
d'expression propres à la culture d'un
sol dans le langage courant ou parle de
cela cnes le laisser aller
et là c'est le moment où la femme
dominée décide de ce qu'elle fait de son
corps
[Applaudissements]
une émancipation moder dans une société
jamaïcaine curieuse et 7 6
on ne le voit très certainement que du
mauvais côté dans la vie il y a toujours
en bons et mauvais côtés
peut-être qu'en le regardant de
l'extérieur on ne verra que son idée
côté sans l'avoir vécu de l'intérieur
sans avoir connu toutes les missions
qu'il voit dedans
en écoutant les mêmes choses on ne verra
que les mauvaises choses le dl / c'est
génial le dancehall pour les danseurs
c'est un coup à deux vitesses celle que
dieu désire
[Musique]
on blâme sur twitter vibrante très
intelligente et talentueuse
flexible d'accord et vous voyez
l'attitude la
société qui clame que toutes les bonnes
secondes sur un cercle
à l'université des west indies à
kingston sont déjà stanley mia étudie le
dancehall sous tous ses aspects au
département de rigueur tu dises
historiquement et socialement son regard
est donc celui d'un professeur chercheur
une analyse poussée du dancehall qui
permettra de comprendre ce phénomène
culturel dans une jamaïque en proie aux
disparités sociales et aux difficultés
économiques sous fond de complexes
identitaire
le dancehall est clairement les
praticiens naturelle depuis le début de
son histoire dans les plantations jamais
yens et même bien avant ça arrive parce
que bien sûr les populations d'amendé
dans ce nouveau monde fed n'était pas
des gens sans culture
il y à une coupure avec leurs racines
mais pas avec leur culture ils sont donc
venus avec leur musique leur danse et
bien d'autres choses encore
les pistes de danse sont clairement un
espace dans lequel les femmes peuvent
librement s'exprimer
exprimer leur sexualité s'exprimer en
tant que femme surtout
dans un contexte social dans lequel une
femme ne doit pas s'exprimer ainsi
alors partant de ce principe les femmes
partout dans le monde voit le dancehall
comme une pratique libératrice
la danse comme libératrice mais aussi
comme échappatoire
23 heures dans une des banlieues les
plus pauvres et violente de la jamaïque
spanish town un taux de chômage
important ou sur population croissante
et une misère bien présente un quotidien
que thaïs 17 ans et ses amis tentent de
fuir le temps d'un instant
grâce à la danse
[Musique]
les rues de spanish town leur terrain de
jeu et c'est là qu'il répète sans cesse
pour ne laisser place à aucun faux pas
c'est quelque chose qui demande d'avoir
de la détermination du temps de
l'énergie et beaucoup de l'orientation
comment
quand je donne je me sens bien c'est
comme si j'avais tout plein d'énergie
n'a pas mérité de danse et personne ne
le pousse à cet automne l'étude
le rêve de tyrese pouvoir danser sur
scène pour les plus grands il nous
confie se voir un jour danser aux côtés
du king of dance hall benhima
[Musique]
beenie man est une superstar dans son
pays et au delà
malgré les années il reste comme à ses
débuts aussi motivés que charismatique
et le temps
n'aura pas atténué sa notoriété auprès
de toutes les classes sociales ce soir
là c'est pour l'élite économique du pays
qui donnent un concert privé
béni man est un artiste qui a traversé
les années et toucher toutes les
générations et ce qui est bien avec lui
c'est qu'il ne cesse de se réinventer
toujours avec autant de passion et on
peut l'écouter quel que soit l'âge
le dancehall représente notre culture où
je vis à l'étranger est ramené ma
culture dans le pays dans lequel je vis
maintenant c'est partager la vibration
et l'énergie positive de la jamaïque et
septum
lui c'est tommy lee sparta rien à voir
avec le dancehall de beenie man tommy
lee sparta fait du d'un seul gothique un
gens qu'il a lui même développé
je ne fais pas du reggae dancehall j'ai
inventé le quotidien
[Musique]
paroles sombres violente des clips à la
limite du film d'horreur tommy sparta
défend ce style qui trouve aussi des
adeptes au delà des frontières de
jamaïcaine
il ya des gens qui disent que c'est bien
de ceux qui disent que c'est mal sa
fonction
un peu comme tommy lee
alcalines avec son look particulier sa
peau blanchit ses yeux tatoué à une
musique qui est selon lui à l'image d'un
certain style de vie drogue alcool sexe
violence gang célébrités on parle alors
de morale dick et déviances moral
et avec l'arrivée de vybz kartel dans le
pain seul km
tout change dans les années 2000
en imposant lui aussi son propre style
il est rapidement devenu l'un des
artistes les plus populaires de sa
génération
collaborant avec des producteurs
américains roshan james cole et des
artistes comme rihanna nicki minaj ou
encore majeur liseur
mais l'homme s'est brûlé les ailes en
cours d'ascension depuis octobre 2011
vybz kartel est incarcéré pour meurtre
les murs de sa prison en revanche ne
l'empêchent pas décrire et produire ses
chansons malgré son incarcération il
reste continuellement sous le feu des
projecteurs
[Musique]
nous nous sommes rendus dans le ghetto
de gaza apporte mort le fief de vybz
kartel
venir à gaza c'est gaza
c'est l'original gazin la place de pape
ce quartier
c'est ici qu'il a créées porteront
d'ailleurs
un collectif qui a lancé des chanteurs
aujourd'hui bien connus comme pop cannes
où tommy lee sparta
gaza à un ghetto anciennement réputés
comme zone de non droit en proie à la
violence au trafic de drogue et même si
les choses ont quelque peu changé ici la
pauvreté toujours présente un univers
dans lequel le dancehall prend ses
racines avant il y avait beaucoup de
choses qui se passait des choses se sont
améliorées qu'est ce que tu veux dire
par les choses se sont améliorées
beaucoup de distractions de ces choses
là
nous terminons avec une reconversion
totalement surprenante celle de lady saw
devenu aujourd'hui marian hall
les bisso c'était l'artiste féminine par
excellence de la scène dancehall la
queen comme on l'appelait ces paroles
très féministe faisait de la femme une
dominatrice qui contrôle le monde et les
hommes grâce à son appareil génital
mais
aujourd'hui lady saw chante un tout
autre genre de chansons bécosses à edge
dash marian hall devrais-je dire prêche
désormais auprès des fidèles
évangélistes une décision prise après
avoir assisté aux funérailles de duca
puis en décembre 2015 autre chanteuse de
dancehall
c'est là qu'elle dit avoir reçu le
message de dieu
il l'esprit ça m'a parlé dieu si vous ne
l'avez pas compris
et depuis cela j'ai senti qu'il fallait
que je sois baptisé
donc je suis allé me faire baptiser mais
le diable ne voulait pas
c'était durant la période où j tous ces
problèmes avec les autres chanteuses qui
voulaient ma ma couronne je l'aimais
appelé la couronne du diable parce que
les autres chanteuse aurait pu tuer pour
la voir
je travaille avec dieu depuis tout ce
temps et le diable devenir m'apporte
beaucoup défaut de plusieurs manières
plusieurs formes et dieu l'a tenu à
l'écart je suis resté dans ma chambre et
il m'a dit qu'il faut que je reste dans
la bible
quand j'écoute les chansons que je
chantais avant je me dis oh mon dieu le
diable me posséder
le tour de force du dancehall c'est
d'avoir su conquérir le marché
international
malgré ces codes purement jamaïcain le
patois langue non officielle parlée par
la majorité de la population encore et
toujours préservé que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les chansons de dancehall
un dancehall qui connaît encore des
heures de gloire
car la relève semble être assurée
koffi jeunes jamaïcaine on est le plus
bel exemple en peu de temps elle a
réussi à s'imposer auprès d'un public
local et international
elle perpétue à sa manière l'histoire
déjà longue très longue de la culture
d'un seul